[Music]
picture I'm very nervous
seventeen-year-old Julia my heart was
pounding my mouth was dry and my hands
were sweaty because I was about to walk
into my boss's office and ask for my
first pay raise somehow I managed to
negotiate my rate from 725 an hour to
10 years later when I found myself in a
similar position you'd think I might
have felt a bit older and wiser going in
but I didn't negotiating your pay isn't
something you get a lot of practice
doing and it's not like they teach it in
high school or college and most people
don't even like to talk about how much
they make with anyone even their boss a
study in Australia found that only 48%
of men and 32% of women thought their
pay was even up for discussion here
income is the most powerful tool that
you have to grow your financial
stability so you owe it to yourself to
exert some control over it
[Music]
the first step in getting a pay raise is
to decide to ask for one in a perfect
world your boss would notice all your
hard work and say hey that employees a
real benefit to this company I should
increase their salary and I'll give them
a company car and a corner office while
I'm at it but this just doesn't happen
in the real world your boss might even
recognize your value but he or she
probably has their own budget to worry
about so they're unlikely to increase
their expense
without you initiating the conversation
however before you do that you've got to
prepare your case how are you especially
valuable to the company what
achievements or successes have you had
recently have your responsibilities
expanded beyond the original job
description any extra training or
education relevant to your work it's
best not to compare your paid to other
employees that's not considered
professional and don't include personal
needs like my rent went up or my dog got
sick employers will only care about your
individual merit and remember that just
with your job
is not a good enough argument after all
you already agreed to do that when you
first took the position you have to show
that you're more valuable now than you
were when you were hired although you're
arming yourself with arguments keep in
mind that it's not a battle replacing an
established employee is very expensive
and time-consuming so if you're a good
worker your boss probably wants the same
thing you do for you to be happy enough
to stick around unless they're an
abusive jerk in which case would getting
a raise really make you happier maybe
you should be looking for a different
job instead have a specific number in
mind researchers at Columbia Business
School found that workers were more
likely to get a raise if they asked for
a precise amount probably because they
seemed more confident about their worth
but you do have to be realistic
most pay raises are between one and five
percent and you can use websites like a
pay scale or Glassdoor to find out the
market rate for your position in your
area timing is key if the company is in
the middle of a big project and your
boss is stressed out you might want to
wait for things to calm down before
asking for a raise
plan your request soon after you've
completed a big achievement or shown
that you can successfully handle more
responsibilities and if you've recently
taken a vacation or missed a deadline
you should probably allow some time to
re-establish a reliability asking at the
right time will only make it easier for
your boss to say yes even if your
employer thinks you deserve it they just
might not have the ability to increase
your salary which is why you should be
ready with alternate options salary only
typically accounts for about 70% of
employees total compensation which
leaves lots of room on the negotiating
table for other benefits and perks and
you can get creative there's gym
membership reimbursement professional
development funding commuting expense
coverage more flexible work hours heck
maybe it's just a cubicle that's as far
as possible from the obnoxiously loud
co-worker come up with the top three
things you would change about your job
and see if they're amenable when you've
got your presentation planned out it's
time to rehearse the thought of
explaining why you deserve more money
makes most people want to crawl under a
rock but it's important that you appear
confident in your self-assessment so
have a friend or family member sit down
with you and who doesn't get some
stumble through is out of the way the
mirror isn't gonna cut it here you need
to sit across from a human being who can
ask you questions that your employer
might bring up during your talk and
don't ask for feedback from your
rehearsal partner until you've gone
through it at least a couple times and
lastly be prepared to hear know even if
you walk out of your boss's office with
nothing more than what you went in with
it's not a defeat you have successfully
communicated your expectations about
your career and shown your investment in
the company long-term trust me your
employer will remember these things the
next time you're up for of you or a
promotion becomes available you'll also
be giving yourself practice and asking
for what you want something that is
difficult for a surprising number of
people but essential to feeling like you
have control over your life ask my
mother-in-law always says if you don't
ask the answer is always no so there's
no harm in trying if you do it with
preparation and professionalism and you
won't have to wonder whether you could
be making more
and that's our two cents
you